- Talk about gorgeous human
beings, huh, David Rubin?
(audience applauds)
Smoking hot, smoking.
(audience laughs)
Well, now that the veil has been lifted,
this is what the
Governors Ball looks like,
and I'm telling everybody.
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna tell everybody
what's going on in here.
I'm very happy to be here tonight
just to honor these special people,
but I'll keep it brief
'cause I know you have dinner
reservations someplace else.
(audience laughs)
I'm here to introduce a film
clip showing you the work
of one of the greatest minds
ever to walk this country
of the United States,
(audience applauds)
probably the most attractive,
intelligent woman I've ever
had the pleasure to work with,
who saved my life on multiple
occasions professionally,
and I think it says it all right there.
Look at the look on that gal's face.
It says, "I know more than you do,
"and I'm still gonna
be real nice about it."
(audience laughs)
She's the greatest.
Let's see what she did.
Let's see if she can really prove it.
She's not supposed to be here tonight,
but you're gonna get to
see this fantastic clip.
This is the work, some of
the work of Elaine May.
(audience applauds)